and I'm gonna talk about the major
partition property and the secretary
problem this is based on joint work with
I know curling Nathan Klein and shine
always final
throughout the talk assume is a ground
set of elements and double use a
non-negative weight function on these
elements also let Sigma be uniform the
random ordering of the elements
so first I'm going to talk about the
secretary problem which is a special
case of the Matrix signature problem
this the secondary problems origin is
sort of vague but by the 50s it was
known by different names to many
researchers so the secondary problem is
an online problem in which elements
arrive in a random order and when an
element arrives we learn its weight and
must make an irrevocable decision
whether to accept it or not and we can
only take
um and accept one element
it is widely known that there is a
there's a secretary algorithm a uh star
with confidence ratio one over e which
means that for any weight function the
expected weight of the elements accepted
by a star where the expectation is taken
over uh the random order is at least one
over e times the value of the most
valuable item so this ratio is optimal
it's known but um you know and and I I
will uh you know use uh a a a star to
refer to this algorithm in in the rest
of the talk
okay
um
so here I won't talk more about the
optimal algorithm it's analysis but I'm
going to go over a very similar
algorithm and prove that it's it has
competitive ratio one over four and at
least one over four
so in the first part of the algorithm
reject the first half of the stream but
keep track of the weight of the most
valuable element among them
and in the second half as new elements
arrive except the first element with the
weight is greater than or equal to the
weight of the most valuable element in
the first half
so to see why this algorithm has
completed ratio uh whatever four
consider uh the the weight that uh sorry
consider um consider the event that the
the second most valuable element comes
in the first half and the most valuable
element comes in the second half and in
in this in this case the algorithm
accepts the the best elements
so the problem of this event is one over
four and you know this implies that the
completed ratio is at least one over
four
now the optimal algorithm a star is very
similar to this algorithm only in the
first part of the algorithm it rejects
the first one over e fraction of the
elements and uh as opposed to one over
two so
um you know with a more careful analysis
uh one can show that a star has
completed ratio one over e but here you
know this the idea is very similar
um
so the major secondary problem is a
generalization
generalization of the secondary problem
as I mentioned and before defining the
problem I briefly talk about Metroid and
give some useful examples image with m
is a set function on a ground set e with
nice properties that generalizes the
notion of linear Independence for a
finite set of vectors so if we refer to
the family of subsets on the ground set
e as the independent sets of the Metroid
you know I won't formula Define Matrix
but if you you don't know the definition
you can think about them in terms of the
examples I'm about to mention so as I
mentioned
metroids generalize linear Independence
so given any finite set of vectors in
the K dimensional Vector space over an
arbitrary field F the sound of linearly
independent subsets of e forms the
independent sets of a matrix called
linear majority
and if the vector space is over the
field the finite fee with two elements
we call it a binary Metroid and a binary
Metroid you know a binary metroids are
important to our result and I will talk
about them more and give some examples
later
uh another
members is partition Metroid so given a
partitioning of a ground set e we can
define a matrix called the partition
Metroid with the following Independence
sets any subset of e is independent if
and only if it contains at most one
element from each part of the partition
and uh partition methods are also
crucial to our discussion in this talk
and they'll show up a lot so
as an example here given this partition
um and of the ground set the first two
sets are independent but the third the
third one is not independent because it
has two elements from the last part
also throughout the talk it seemed that
the parts uh of the partition are
indexed in a decreasing order of their
sizes just for Simplicity
so finally for any graph we Define a
Metroid called a graphic Metroid and on
the set of element set of edges so the
grounds of the set of the edges of the
Matrix of the of the graph
and independent sets are the set of
edges that don't contain any cycle
I won't explain this but this is not
hard to show that any graphic network is
a binary Metroid
so now we're ready to Define
um you know major signature problem the
major secondary problem is an online
problem introduced in a beautiful and
influential paper by Baba youth in more
immoralika and kleinberg in 2007
and it's probably given a Metroid in
advance and elements of the ground set
arrive in a random order and when an
element arrives we learn its weight and
must make an irrevocable decision
whether to accept e or not
so the point of the problem the Metroid
is that accept accepted elements must be
an independent set in the Metroid
so in the same paper the authors
conjecture that there is a major
secondary algorithm with constant
competitive ratio I mean more precisely
there is a constant C such that for any
major there is a randomized major
secretary algorithm that for any weight
function the expected value of the
elements accepted by the algorithm is at
least c times the weight of the best
independent set
um and the expectation here is taken
over uh the random order and the
randomization inside the algorithm
this problem is motivated by
applications in online auction Theory
but discussing the applications beyond
the scope of this talk
okay so since this conjecture was
introduced many have worked on his
problem but still it Still Remains open
in the original paper the author is
given a algorithm with competitive ratio
Omega one over log rank where rank is
the size of the maximum you can set up
the Metroid
and later others improve this to Omega
one over uh square root of log Rank and
then Omega one over log log rank
um there are also various results that
achieve a constant competitive ratio but
for special classes of major AIDS and
including graphic Matrix uh transfer
some Metroid and laminar metroids and
regular metroids
so here's the outline of the rest of the
talk first I'm going to define the
Matrix partition property and the
partition reduction based algorithm
algorithms
um and partition reduction based
algorithms are class of algorithms that
achieve constant competitive ratio for
many classes of metroids including
graphic Matrix Lamar Matrix transmitter
metroids and these algorithms are based
on a generalization of the Matrix
partition property which I will Define
shortly given the power of partition
reduction based algorithms some
researchers began asking whether one can
design a partition reduction based
algorithm that has a constant
competitive ratio for all metroids and
our main contribution in this work is
showing that there is no partition
reduction based algorithm that has
constant competitive ratio for all
metroids
so partitional reduction based
algorithms are based on
reducing the given Matrix to a partition
Metroid I will explain more precisely
what a reduction means but
before that it's useful to mention that
there is a very simple Matrix secretary
algorithm for partition Metroid that has
a constant competitive ratio
um
you know with others as follows for any
partition Metroid P it is enough to run
our optimal classical uh secondary
algorithm a star on each part separately
and you know
um
clearly the set of excellent elements is
Independence is the algorithmic steps at
most one element from each part
and also the exact value of accepted
elements is the sum of expected values
of elements accepted by a star in each
part and recall that a star has
completed ratio one over e so the
capacity ratio of a p star is also at
least one over e
so I will say uh I will use AP star
to refer to this algorithm in during the
rest of the talk
okay now we say a major M Prime is a
reduction of Metroid M if it's ground
set is a subset of the ground set of M
and any of its independencies is also
independent setting M for example here M
Star sorry MN Prime is a reduction of M
one can easily check
so we say Metroid M has the alpha
partition property for a constant Alpha
if we can randomly construct a partition
Matrix P that's a reduction of M and for
all weight functions the value of the
best independent p is at least one over
Alpha times the value of the best
independent set in m
so if a Metroid satisfies Alpha
partition property it's easy to design
an algorithm with constant competent
ratio for it it's enough to reduce the
Metroid to the partition Matrix P given
by Alpha partition property before
seeing any of the string and then run
the algorithm AP star on the Stream
it can be shown that any graphic Metroid
actually satisfy two partition property
which means that for any graphic Midway
based on the graph G we can randomly
construct a partition method that's a
reduction of graphic Matrix and for all
weight functions W the best value of
Independence setting p is at least half
of the value of the best spanning Forest
of the graph G
and then this implies that there's a
micro secretary algorithm with constant
competent ratio for uh with like
actually two one over two e competitive
ratio for graphic Matrix
so let me give an overview of the proof
given a partition method on sorry given
a graphic method on graph G and randomly
construct a partition Metroid as follows
first we direct the edges from graph and
you know the edges of the graph G to get
a directed graph G Prime to do so with
probably one half Orient every Edge from
the vertex the smaller index towards the
vertex with the larger index but
otherwise Orient every Edge from the
vertex with the larger index of the
varieties with the small index now let
the ice part of the partition be all
edges directed towards vertex I in G
Prime
the first thing I want you to show is
that P is a reduction of M which is
equal to saying that any independent
setting P does not contain any cycle in
in the graph G
um now this is not hard to show uh I
skipped this part
second we need to show that value of the
best Independence and partition function
in Partition Metroid is at least one
over two of the value of the best
independent set in m and or the best
spanning forest in G and let's assume
for example that g is connected and the
analysis is the same or if it's
disconnected
um so consider the optimal independent
set in in m in which is a 3ng and let's
assume you know let's let's root the
tree uh at an arbitrary vertex and then
direct each Edge from the parents toward
the child
so for every directed h i j we probably
won't have the direction is the same in
the graph G Prime in that case PJ
contains a directed h i j and since the
other Edge is incident to J
um in the directory are outgoing edges
no other directed Edge from this tree is
in PJ
this means that the pro we probably
won't have the weight of the best
element in of PJ is at least the value
of H I J and uniquely corresponds to it
also so in expectation the value of the
best independent set of p is at least
half of the value of the tree
okay so in their summary of the major
sector problem Dennis asked where
whether all metroids have the alpha
partition property for some Universal
constant Alpha and a corollary of our
result which I will talk about surely is
that there are main choice that do not
satisfy this property
I mentioned that if a matrix size is
Alpha protection property for constant
Alpha then there is a major secretary
algorithm with constant competitive
ratio based on a reduction of the given
Metroid to a partition method but such
an algorithm reduces the given method to
a partition method without knowing any
of the weights but one can consider a
more General class of algorithms
better based on reductions to partition
metroids and as okay what if we first
see the weights of the of a fraction of
the elements and use this knowledge to
reduce the to reduce the meter to a
partition Metroid and on the rest of the
elements you know and then run a the
algorithm for partition Metroid on on
the constructed partition Metroid
so more precisely
um
consider the following the setup
algorithms so first give an image and
choose beta because zero and one then
reject the first beta fraction of
elements but based on the weights of
these elements reduce M to a partition
Matrix p with ground set is a subset of
the rest of the elements okay I'll call
this set up all elements on E that are
not in the partition Metroid R so here's
an image
then having a prodigymetric p run AP
star on the rest of the string in
addition to graphic my choice you know
which we discussed before there are
partition reduction based algorithm for
transversal metroids and linear metroids
and that have constant competitive
competitive ratio and as opposed to the
reduction for graphic metroids these
reductions are constructed after seeing
the weights of a fraction of the
elements
so it wasn't you know because
um you know that this class of
algorithms have a great performance on
various classes of metroids and people
wondered whether there is a reduction
based algorithm with constant
competitive ratio for all metroids
and
um our main theorem is that there is no
partition reduction base algorithm that
achieves constant competitive ratio on
binary metroids which I defined shortly
but
um you know and this main theorem
suggests that for resolving major
secretary contexture affirmly one needs
to look for algorithms outside this
class
okay let me first Define the complete
binary Metroid the complete value
Metroid a BD is a binary Metroid on all
elements of the K dimensional Vector
space on the finite field with two
elements so the size of the ground set
is 2 to the D minus 1 and recall the
independences of this Matrix are all
sets of vectors that are linearly
independent
so here you can see all the elements of
B3 and Below there are two examples of
independent sets and the third set
however is not independent because the
sum of these three vectors is zero
so we derive our main theorem which I
mentioned uh earlier
um
from another theorem and this other
theorem is written
um
above and so rough is looking this
theorem says that for any reduction of
BD to a partition Matrix p with all uh
you know you know with parts P1 to PD
almost all elements of P are
concentrated in very few parts so more
precisely excluding the larger order of
square root D parts of the partition all
other parts combined
contain only D to the minus one over
four fraction of the elements of the
binary method
so our main theorem is a corollary of
this room and you know to State
um or main Theory more precisely again
this uh
and we proved that given a d that is
large enough any reduction based
algorithm that has competent Rich at
most D to the minus one over four
and um
you know first I want to explain on High
level how we derive the corollary which
is our main theorem from the above
theorem
okay so the proof idea is as follows for
example the elements from the grounds
that of BD uniformly at random bit
replacement and then let the weight of
these elements be 1 and the weight of
the rest of the elements be zero
so it's not hard to see that expectation
of the best Independence set has at
least there were too many elements with
weight one
on the other hand for any partition
Metroid the optimal Independence that
has at most order of D to the three
fourth many elements with weight one so
like too little
because to see this we have we use the
above theorem since the elements with
weight one are distributed uniformly the
above theorem implies that most of these
elements are concentrated in the OR in
order of square root the largest part of
the partition and
you know any um Independence set of this
partition meter can only take one
element from each of these large parts
so the gain from them would be at most
square root d and you know in the rest
of the parts in expectation there will
be at most order of D to the three
fourths many elements with weight one
all combined so to gain from these parts
uh is at most order of D to the three
fourths
which
um
gives us what we wanted it's just a
proof idea
um so let's assume this is proved
now it remains to prove this theorem
so then a reminder when dd is reduced to
p
by definition of reduction the ground
set of p is a subset of M so the
elements of M might fall outside so some
of the elements of M might fall outside
of p and I denote the rest of the
elements of BD that are not in P by r
so
how do we prove this theorem
um so be Professor by an inductive
application of a Lemma that says that
the largest part of the partition is
very large and just inductively we
um
we prove this theorem so the proof of
this part is you know this that this
induction
um gives the theorem is not hard and um
I won't talk about it but an important
point to mention is that allowing P to
not contain all elements of the binary
metric is a fundamental point about this
number since without allowing this by
induction the induction would not go
even go through
um
so here uh I want to mention two related
papers in independent work from ours uh
literature mostly improves
um showed that for any constant B the
Metroid BD is uh b
um
a little o of square root D in
decomposable I won't explain what this
means but for b equal to 1 this implies
that for any partition measure that is a
reduction of bdn contains all elements
of VD or equally assuming R is the
entity set the largest part of the
partition has at least Omega one over
square root D fraction of the elements
in a subsequent work Vanderpool shows a
similar result which you know in the it
implies that for you know for first
after setting b equal to one implies
that for any partition metric that is a
reduction of bdn contains a random
subset of the elements of BD or
equivalently assuming that R is a random
subset the largest part of the partition
has little uh Omega of one over D
fraction of elements and with high
probability and these you know you can
see these results are neither strong or
weaker than the Lemma written above and
to the and to the based on my knowledge
because of these assumptions and R that
these results have then they cannot be
applied in that level to get get the
above theorem
in the rest of the talk I want to focus
on this Lemma but in this time to
demonstrate the main idea of the proof I
proved the dilemma with the extra
assumption that P includes all elements
of n or equivalently R is empty so I
proved this simplified version
so I start with a simple fact
given partition metric that is a
reduction of BD for any elements X and Y
that are in different parts I and J the
sum of the elements is either in part I
or in part J
so why the proof is very simple but you
know since the since the set X Y and X
Plus Y is a dependent set they can't be
in three different parts of the
partition so you know the fact follows
so you're ready to prove the Lemma in
the simplified form and in the proof let
N be the number of elements that is 2 to
the D minus one so
the proof falls from a double counting
argument uh it's still a contradiction
that the size of P1 is less than n over
eight okay and considering graph on the
elements whose edges are pairs of
elements that are in different parts
okay so um here I have partially
specified the partition elements of B4
and they're on the edges based on these
partitions so for instance like one
there is no Edge between one and two
because they're in the same Parts P2
now first let's lower bound the number
of edges the number of edges in the is
the total number of pairs of elements in
the Metroid which is n choose two and
the number of pairs of elements that are
um in so minus minus the number of pairs
of the elements that are in the same
part of the party in the same you know
part of the partition
um so considering the Assumption we made
by contradiction the second term is
maximized when there are eight parts of
size n over eight and the rest of the
parts are empty it's not hard to see
using this fact we can upper bound the
this term by N squared over eight
if all the number of edges can be
bounded below by N squared over four
now we find an upper bound on the number
of edges for this purpose
um
make the graph directed as follows
so we call it for every age X and Y
where X is important and Y is in part J
and if the Sun is in part you know sorry
that the sum is either in part I or in
part J
um and you know if the part if the sum
is in part J direct The Edge towards Y
and otherwise it's toward X
so in this example I'm showing the
direction of one of the edges just say
the age between two and three and some
of the elements 23 is element one which
is in part two and element two is in
part two as well so the direction is
from three to two
now consider an arbitrary vertex X of
the graph that is um say in part I and
consider two arbitrary incoming edges Y
X and Y Prime X
Y and X Plus y prime or two have to have
to be two distinct elements in NPI so
any Edge directed towards X
corresponds to a unique element in pi
and therefore the degree of X is at most
the size of Pi
which is n over 8 by our assumption and
this gives an upper bound on the size of
a
the number of edges which is N squared
over eight and clearly this contradicts
the lower boundary derived earlier
okay to summarize applying this Lemma
when we can prove this theorem that says
that for any reduction of complete
binary Metroid to a partition Metroid
almost all elements of the partition are
concentrated in very few parts and a
corollary of this theorem is our main
theorem that says no partition-based
algorithm and partition reduction based
algorithm has a constant competitive
ratio for complete binary metroids
finally here are some open problems
beside the obvious open problem that is
the major secondary conjecture in
general form I think our work confirms
that graphic matriaries do not really
capture the behavior of General binary
Choice with respect to this problem and
the binary measures are hard instances
so one might want to focus on binary
metroids and try to find out whether
there is a major secretary algorithm
with constant competitive ratio for
binary matriots and second and more
vague questions and to consider is that
can we use reductions to other classes
of my choice to design a Metroid
secretary algorithm with constant
competitive ratio for all metroids
thank you